start digging right there right there
see right there
well is he in you see is only that
there's something silver down there oh
hey it's pretty big
what is that it takes some sort of note
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to another episode of the
outdoor boys YouTube channel today we're
doing a little metal detecting a good
friend of mine invited us to come over
to his farm and do a little searching
around and see if we could find anything
and he lives in a pretty historic
location a lot of Civil War battlefields
and and things like that in this area so
I'm excited we might see something and
find something but it's a cold wet day
today and we're just excited to get out
and do something because you get a
little bit of cabin fever I think
[Music]
okay we've got a mouse infestation my
garage look like I just found my sleeve
there's tons of it in here it's I use it
for carp bait but the mice have been
taking it and storing it in my sleeve
need to set more mice traps
all right here's my metal detector it's
the prism for it's made by a company
called whites and it served me pretty
well it's it's not a bad mid-range metal
detectors getting a little old I think
it's a no 10-15 years old now but I'm
used a lot and the boys got some of
these little Bounty Hunter junior metal
detectors all right so my friend came
out here and told me that there was
actually some Civil War encampments over
in this field behind the house so we're
definitely gonna go over there I think
we're gonna make a quick sweep around
the house just to get warmed up see if
we can't find any old coins or anything
like that
and eventually I do want to go and poke
around here and see if we can find any
old farm implements so we're gonna kind
of see what happened and it's been a
while since I've done any serious metal
detecting so I'm a little rusty but
we'll see what happens all right guys
come on here's metal in these rocks the
metal detectors are just going bonkers
on these rocks I think there's some iron
ore in there or something so we're gonna
go get out into the farmer's field to
try that
know what this is is a cornfield see
look at this is something about the
rocks here just pings the crap out of
the the nickel and the iron and it's
just setting my detector off look looks
like someone's been detecting here hole
well if I was a Civil War soldier I'd
put my tent on top of a little hill so
I'm on the hill here and we'll see what
see what we can find
usually when I'm getting the false
readings i zip my metal detector over it
beings once and I zip over the same spot
another direction and it doesn't being
that tells you it's a phantom reading
each direction it should get clearer as
you dig if it gets more confused as you
dig and everything in this soil is
coming up nickel
oh here comes the train well it looks
like Tommy found the first treasure why
don't you show ya a little shotgun shell
casing look at that yeah it's the casing
it's what's left over when you shoot a
bullet anything that one's all plastic
Wow there you go bud
there's this treasure bag you want me to
put my camera in there
[Music]
oh yeah look inside that tree guys it's
a collar
this place is kind of frustrating the
rocks in the ground just set off my
metal detector like crazy
I mean look just just constant I can
tell they're bogus readings because
they're kind of disappear on me see
they're kind of it's not very crisp yeah
but you get reading like my ring it's
nice and crisp when it's a good reading
it'll give me a steady depth signal when
it's a bad reading the depth kind of
jumps all over the place and disappears
they can't get a depth reading but I
think the boys are getting a little sick
of this so we're going to go over to the
barn and see if we can find any cool
artifacts by the barn
yeah they still use this guy's is where
they used to keep cows the cows go put
their heads through the bars and they
clamp their heads and they can come back
here and Mel Cove or whatever there's
like four Xerox machines back here one
of those doing here
Hey look at this guy this is the silo
the east half conveyor belts then put
cow feed and we count food up in there
do this yeah look at you didn't find the
shovel yeah you that you see right there
yeah that's a proper signal alright Tom
come here bud this is probably a piece
of the silos room fitted and they're all
over coming up pull tabs oh there's lots
of brambles here look at this
what'd you find Nathan are you detecting
your brother again he's a robot
stop metal detecting your brother's
bottom it's good we're doing this in the
winter town we'd be so full of ticks if
we did it in the summer
Nathan did you say you love moonshine
oh yeah lots of groundhogs in here
aren't there
Legos groundhog holes man I'm still
getting tons and tons of these false
signals what was it yeah these rocks
have a lot of metal in them isn't that
crazy
yeah look at that
that's a golf-ball skin no I think I saw
the guts over here here it is look right
here that's that's the guts of a golf
ball right there yeah that's the inside
of a golf ball this look it is yeah it's
a giant bolt too like a tractor flap
this back overlay then all right guys
let's go get some food I'm hungry how
about you guys
well we didn't get rich we didn't find
tons of Civil War relics but we had a
good time didn't we we actually did
another metal detecting video that we
already were actually were quite
successful and I'll post a link in the
description and me and Nathan did a
magnet fishing video a while ago we had
a lot of fun even caught an eel magnet
fishing and I'll put a link in the
description of that as well but thanks
for watching we hope you guys have a
good time don't forget to click yeah if
you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button so you'll get
notifications thanks for watching